nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi quand tu étais au pays que j'aime à
dire de cette vente est le lion le plus
patient de la terre et serviable
seulement faut pas me prendre pour un
mouton bons ballons vie puisqu'il faut
balayer balayons plus chétifs tu
m'amènes avec toi ce que je fais pas la
fête
je pourrais titi m'aider alors pour
commencer ne veut plus de papier par
terre
tu es tu m'avais zimmer je m'en fais
et voilà le travail tout le monde est
n'importe quoi par terre cette étude du
ballet alors titus tu te puce comme
d'habitude pas tu as de la chance tu
n'as jamais trop chaud toit ni son ni
fois son nom c'est moi qui nettoie on le
dirait pas je pâlis et dégoûtant
commente à lui désormais ce cas on se
prend pour le grand dakar bonjour mon
gars est heureux de te voir je vais te
montre à mon dernier tour de
prestidigitation pas mal de corps à
corps les miettes et en gros soit sans
importance l'esl est aubin et pousse toi
attention akabia cap blanc et voilà
c'est raté
tout est en petits morceaux dans mon
enfance mais c'est un tonneau ce jeu vie
de tous les jours on commence un au nom
dire ça un artiste comme moi
titus plus on arrivera en gras ou pas
seulement d'une étoile et ça regarde
immenses portes des phases d'artistes au
rock qui se gêne pas voilà vous que
c'est fini tout est propre aux non
troppo même crâne pour un aspirateur qui
tisse un hyper les parkings il est
multiple est né soyez juste grâce à
plusieurs années et puis on fait des
saletés territoire et travaille au lieu
d'être obligé je vous croyais que je
m'amuse sommes alors ça va sauver
je vais m'amuser et une foire axes de
travail alors les gars banon se valent
34' roulant la côte est agréable tu sais
ce qu'est ce que tu fais le travail
grand yaka de travail
quel plaisir de travailler dans la voix
et tu peux vraiment beaucoup de plaisir
et payer comme c'est un titus en plaisir
incroyable quel dommage que vous n'ayez
pas ce plaisir grand yaka déclic je veux
la clé remet le pc que tu as ce site
c'est la voile et le cheval est le seul
à travailler
vous voulez mon balai
le voici le voilà c'est le ballet du
ballet qui veut mon ballet quand le plus
adroit de la prade font pas je vais j'y
vais de benedetti
je veux travailler comme titus je veux
le même plaisir que titus le même
document goliath avancer mon balai il
est à vous voyez comme il fallait bien
eu moins espérer un mois de l'année les
ventes de montres ou tu fais titus en
force et le ballet oui on est bien le
manque les élus d'abord assez périlleux
c'est merveilleux
je travaille je travaille le site
agréable
non c'est pas sur place promenez vous
dans votre palais un peu mal pour le
ballet et la prochaine fois qu'il me
dira d'un travail et d'un père qu'il me
reste à faire
et après après est une autre histoire